al final de la calle creo que esta es
una de las puertas de la ciudad
hace tres meses que ya se instaló en
este apartamento de cracovia Polonia con
su hijo huyeron de la ofensiva rusa y
tuvieron que abandonar su ciudad natal
no entiendo las acciones de los rusos
dicen que defienden su país se defienden
a sí mismos
pero son ellos los que vinieron aquí
destruyeron la pobre ciudad de hard
porque la necesitan ahí no queda nada
y ya huyó en el pasado en 1941 judía
tenía solo 10 años cuando los nazis
invadieron Ucrania
Papá tenía pánico dijo que teníamos que
irnos teníamos que hacer las maletas y
marcharnos pero ya era imposible porque
desde el 9 de julio había tal pánico
todos los que podían huían los
comunistas los judíos y todos los demás
también se iban finalmente consiguió
llegar a harkiff con su familia antes de
cruzar la mitad de la unión soviética
con designó atasquent en Uzbekistán a
más de 3.500 kilómetros de su hogar
viajamos en barco de vapor y luego en
vagón de carga hasta llegar a tasquén
salimos de harkies el 21 de Septiembre
el día 29 tuvo lugar la masacre de
babillar la masacre de babillar uno de
los peores episodios del holocausto el
29 y 30 de septiembre de 1941 los nazis
fusilaron y mataron a más de 33.500
judíos en un Barranco del Oeste de kiev
Y ya y su familia regresaron finalmente
a la capital ucraniana tras la guerra 81
años después tuvo que hacer las maletas
de nuevo esta vez con dirección a
Polonia a su pesar quiero ir a casa Solo
para salir y hablar con mis vecinos en
un idioma que entendamos hoy desde su
ventana pueden ver una bandera rusa
colgada del ruso en cracovia y ya
prefiere mirar hacia otro lado donde la
calle dice le recuerda a las de